bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo bonjour au dojo à tous
votre rendez vous avec les temps forts
de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire pas de trêve en dépit des
vacances scolaires cette semaine on le
voit tout de suite en images avec
d'abord eric besson qui relance le débat
sur l'identité nationale 2 mois de
discussions avec les forces vives de la
nation
une initiative qui divise à droite et à
gauche certains dénoncent une opération
de diversion électorale la france passée
compte à l'assemblée nationale les
députés cherchent des mesures symbole
pour remplir les caisses par temps de
crise
il échoue sur la taxation des profits
des banques mais adobe que la
suppression des avantages des sportifs
professionnels
et puis une semaine également marquée
par deux coups de tonnerre judiciaire la
condamnation à un an de prison ferme de
charles pasqua dans la sphère de
l'angolagate et le renvoi en
correctionnelle de jacques chirac sur le
dossier des emplois fictifs de la mairie
de paris est avec nous pour commenter
l'actualité cette semaine gilles carez
bonjour moi je veux être avec nous vous
êtes député ump du val de marne tout le
monde connaît votre nom pour la fameuse
loi car elle qui en 96 régissait les
règles de superficie pour les ventes de
logements et puis vous êtes depuis cinq
ans rapporteur général de la commission
des finances
vous allez donc pouvoir nous dire si la
discussion budgétaire qui s'est terminée
cette semaine dans sa partie recette a
été pour vous de mémoire deux
rapporteurs l'une des plus difficiles
alors vous allez vous que vous avez
beaucoup pesé sur la fameuse réforme de
la taxe professionnelle vous avez révisé
la copie du gouvernement
on le verra on reproche au député malgré
tout d'avoir parfois manger leur chapeau
sur un certain nombre d'initiatives vous
nous direz si vous êtes d'accord
et vous nous donnerez aussi votre avis
sur les dépenses de la présidence
française de l'union européenne
voilà on commence donc avec la journée
du lundi est le grand retour du thème de
l'identité nationale
le débat sur l'identité nationale sera
donc lancé le 2 novembre dans toutes les
préfectures initiative du ministre eric
besson particulièrement actif depuis
quelques semaines levée de boucliers à
gauche et au modem
c'est en tout cas le retour de l'un des
thèmes phares de la campagne électorale
de nicolas sarkozy en 2007 pierre bande
joseph un tgv des juges une soupe
populaire voilà résumée en quelques
images la devise républicaine
en plus d'une formation linguistique ce
film est projeté aux français
naturalisés dans le cadre du contrat de
naturalisation voulue par brice
hortefeux est créée en 2007
un dispositif incomplet pour eric besson
étrangers qui arrivent sur notre sol je
voudrais d'abord qu'ils parlent mieux le
français
je pense que sans l'apprentissage de la
langue c'est pour ça qu'on leur propose
de le faire dès leur pays d'origine
il n'y a pas d' intégration possible sur
le sol français est un prérequis disons
à la formation et mystique mais la
question d'intégration beaucoup plus
vaste donc sa porte sur plein d'autres
domaines notamment serait drôle
logements et là en général ils tombent
en droit commun ce lacarne spéciale qui
est fait pour les immigrés
le ministre de l'immigration veut aussi
ouvrir un chantier est de taille celui
de l'identité nationale mais difficile
pour les associations des deux immigrés
d'adhérer à des valeurs quand les titres
de séjours sont de plus en plus courts
ne serait-ce que ce soit pour le travail
votre séjour est susceptible d'être mis
en cause tous les hommes
croyez-vous car l'employeur sa chance à
l'assemblage est facilement et bien sûr
là d'éléments d'un emploi en poupe rp
rennes
attaqué sur sa gauche après le retour
forcé de trois afghans dans leur pays un
pays en guerre eric besson assume et
reprend la main à quatre mois des
régionales l'ump relance ans et un de
ses thèmes favoris celui de
l'immigration
est ce que ce débat vous paraît vraiment
utile en ce moment une thérèse passé à
débat difficile
la question de l'identité nationale elle
travers cette histoire depuis des
siècles déjà à la fin du 19e
lorsque nous avons eu les afflux
d'immigration important c'est une
question d'actualité moi je trouve les
plus belles pages sur l'idée tenté
d'identité nationale ont été écrites pas
par ernest renan et pour moi mais
justement il était cité par alain juppé
qui sont blom dit au fond l'identité
nationale c'est la volonté de vivre
ensemble et à peut-être marié loin d'en
faire un débat
oui justement vivre ensemble à partir
d'une histoire à partir de valeur d'une
culture
et puis à partir aussi d'une langue
partagée et je trouve que eric besson a
tout à fait raison d'insister sur
l'apprentissage de la langue parce que
le partage de la langue tout notre
histoire le monde c'est le début du
creuset c'est à partir de la langue que
s'assimile les différentes types
d'immigration et donc c'est là dessus
qu'on doit faire porter l'effort et si
ce débat qui est difficile qui doit pas
tomber dans le populisme peut déboucher
sur quelque chose d'utile
ce sera au niveau avant tout de
l'éducation de l'apprentissage de la
langue est derrière elle des valeurs et
on en vient à votre domaine de
prédilection maintenant gilles carez le
budget en ce lundi les députés termine
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
qui a été âprement discutée cette année
dans sa partie recettes y compris par
vous même et par les députés de votre
majorité
en cette dernière soirée budgétaire
lundi le sacre sans un bouclier fiscal
est préservé et la taxe sur les banques
est annulé yoann là à l'automne le sujet
fait désormais partie des marronniers
budgétaire pour la troisième année
consécutive en hémicycle
voici que l'on reparle du bouclier
fiscal le grand cheval de bataille de
l'opposition quand il s'agira
d'expliquer à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens que la seule catégorie qui
échappera à l'effort nécessaire
ce sera la catégorie des plus
privilégiés alors votre bouclier vous
serez obligé de le reposer tant qu'il
sera devenu insupportable à lever
défendu avec la même vigueur par le chef
de file des députés ump jean françois
copé monsieur hollande juste une chose
regarder la situation fiscale de tous
les pays d'europe
et vous verrez à cette occasion que tout
ce que nous essayons de faire c'est bien
de rester au niveau de la compétitivité
européenne dans ce domaine parce que
sinon
qu'est-ce qui se passe des
délocalisations avant de laisser place à
un autre amendement défendu et c'est une
première par une députée de la majorité
marie-anne montchamp un amendement pour
sortir la crds du bouclier fiscal france
de 2010 n'est plus la france de 2007
l'augmentation de la performance de la
crds cela devient cruciale et c'est
urgent majorité ébranlée mais quelques
minutes plus tard vote sans surprise
contre il est repoussé fin du débat à la
reprise les députés ont un autre sujet
de préoccupation un amendement sur la
taxation des bénéfices des banques
proposée par le socialiste didier migaud
est votée en commission à la surprise
générale par de nombreux députés de la
majorité
échanges de sourires gênés avec la
ministre qui préfère reparler de
cafouillage technique l article 4 bis
vous en souvenez c'est celui qui a été
adoptée notamment à la suite d'une
erreur matérielle reconnu d'ailleurs et
promet aux parlementaires un autre débat
sur le bien fondé de la mesure un peu
plus tard une annonce accueillie avec
beaucoup de scepticisme
y compris dans son propre camp la taxe
sur les banques gilles carez ça vous
sembler une mauvaise idée
la taxe sur les banques dont je me suis
opposé en commission bon j'ai été battue
parce que c'est vrai quelques uns de mes
collègues de la majorité ont adopté cet
amendement
je pense que le dispositif qui consiste
à taxer brutalement d'un seul coup de
10% supplémentaires les banques n'est
pas le bon dispositif
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que l'on
réfléchisse à une contribution plus
importante des banques à la garantie des
dépôts des déposants que sont les
millions de français
et cette garantie elle est aujourd'hui
assurée gratuitement par l'état
je pense que là il ya une piste à
creuser mais vous voyez autant je suis
favorable à la mise en place d'une
contribution des banques à la garantie
générale du système à la garantie des
déposants autant aller inventer un soir
une taxe spécifique sur une année ne
paraît pas très raisonnable alors il ya
un autre point important qui a été
débattue et qui reviendra peut-être
d'ailleurs c'est celui du bouclier
fiscal
est-ce qu'il est encore admissible que
le bouclier fiscal reste tel qu'il est
est certes un peu de sauf conduit qui
fait qu'à chaque effort supplémentaire
ceux qui sont au bouclier en sont
dispensés dans rappelons d'abord que le
bouclier consiste à dire tout simplement
qu'on ne peut pas vous confisquer plus
de la moitié de vos revenus sous forme
d'impôts c'est un principe on ne peut
plus sain nous sommes un des pays où les
prélèvements obligatoires sont les plus
élevés au monde et donc avoir limité à
50% le prélèvement public est une bonne
chose
une fois qu'on a dit ça il faut
considérer d'autres éléments
et pour ma part si jamais dans l'avenir
on été conduit pour faire face aux
gigantesques déficits sociaux a augmenté
le crds ou la csg
bien entendu cette augmentation devrait
être neutralisée au titre du bouclier
personne ne comprendrait que les
personnes qui sont au bouclier qui sont
pas tous dirige d'ailleurs je le dis au
passage mais personne ne comprendrait
que cette augmentation de crds voire de
serge et de csg ne soient pas partagées
par l'ensemble des français
donc pour moi j'ai une approche qui est
vraiment tout à fait pragmatique
1 on a besoin d'une limite aux
prélèvements dans un des pays où les
prélèvements sont plus effet plus élevé
mais deux le jour où nous aurons besoin
d'augmenter les contributions sociales
et bien il faudra en tenir compte pour
ma part vous dirai quand c'est pas cette
haine pour les jeunes c'est à dire
l'année suivante pas d'augmentation de
crds ou deux sièges à l'ordre du jour
moi je suis très clair là-dessus dès de
début 2007 avant dans le cas de la
campagne présidentielle lorsque la
question s'est posée j'ai publiquement
dit qu'il me paraissait pas judicieux
d'intégrer dans le bouclier les
prélèvements sociaux
parce que je savais dès cette époque un
jour ou l'autre nous aurions besoin
d'augmenter ces prélèvements
mais très tôt le problème quand il se
posera est il je répète il ne remet pas
en cause la notion même de
l'impôt l'impôt ne peut pas être
spoliateurs un impôt spoliateurs
décourage les gens au dessus de 50 %
l'impôt devient spoliateurs pour moi le
vrai problème c'est que d'un côté il
faut que la peau ne soit pas
confiscatoire
mais de l'autre il faut que une personne
qui a des revenus importants ne puisse
pas échapper à l'impôt c'est pour ça que
je me suis battue sur le plafonnement
des niches fiscales
on a eu gain de cause non dernier et je
crois beaucoup pas beaucoup d'effet
chiffres oui c'est un peu homéopathique
points mais ces années absolument pas
homéopathique absolument pas aujourd'hui
alors que quelqu'un qui avait des
millions de revenus pouvait ne paient
plus d'impôt du tout ceci est dorénavant
impossible et c'est un principe très
sain la partie recettes du budget a été
adopté donc le mardi par 316 voix contre
227 un budget marqué par la création de
la taxe carbone une réforme en
profondeur de la taxe professionnelle
l'opposition a dénoncé de déficit jamais
atteint avec une prévision de 116
milliards d'euros pour 2010 âgées car
avec de tel déficit parlons un peu du
grand emprunt
est-ce qu'il vous paraissait nécessaire
indispensable
le grand emprunt doit ni complètement
isolée de nos problèmes de déficits sont
liés malgré les dents - non nous pouvons
parfaitement imaginer un emprunt
spécifique un emprunt d'un mode nouveau
qui ne servirait que à alimenter des
avances remboursables à des secteurs
industriels on le fait pour
l'aéronautique qui servirait à alimenter
des fonds pour aider des entreprises des
petites entreprises en fonds propres
pour investir on le fait à travers oseo
qui pourrait alimenter également des
fonds pour aider nos universités c'est
ce qui est fait à travers le plan campus
donc vous voyez un emprunt qui n'a pas
pour vocation d'augmenter les dépenses
publiques mais qui a pour vocation
d'investir avec un retour sur
investissement ça c'est tout à fait
possible sur la taxe professionnelle
c'était aussi un autre gros dossier vie
ble ment il ya eu un petit combat entre
les députés et j'allais dire le
gouvernement est plutôt le medef
1 parce que vous même vous souhaitiez
récupérer un maximum pour les
collectivités locales ce qui aurait
impliqué une pression fiscale accrue sur
les petites entreprises
alors on a fait un travail très
intéressant depuis des mois avec le
gouvernement je suis rapporteur du
budget depuis 2002 c'est la première
fois qu'on travaille vraiment en
confiance avec l'administration depuis
des mois pour arriver à une bonne
réforme
ça se fait aujourd'hui vous dites il ya
encore du travail à faire je suis sûr
qu'il sera fait au sénat cette réforme
elle est d'une ampleur extraordinaire
c'est la plus grosse réforme fiscale que
nous ayons fait est fait depuis des
décennies et le volet entreprise a été
traité mais le volet collectivités
territoriales ne l'a pas été
suffisamment et donc nous avons essayé
de trouver d' améliorer la copie sur le
volet collectivités territoriales tenue
gain de cause sur les communes en
revanche sur sur les entreprises sur les
est là qu on a dit que vous aviez un peu
le député de la jonction les entreprises
nous acculer nous avons un regret parce
que nous nous nous battons notamment
pour une baisse de taxe professionnelle
une baisse de charges générales pour nos
grandes entreprises ou moyennes
entreprises qui sont dans la concurrence
internationale
nous nous battons d'abord pour
l'industrie nous pensons je pense que on
doit tout faire pour garder une
industrie dans notre pays et donc nous
préfèrerions une réforme dans laquelle
la taxe professionnelle et en priorité
baissé sur les entreprises industrielles
quitte à ce que les baisses qui sont
très importantes soit un petit peu moins
importante pour les petites entreprises
le commerce l'artisanat qui sont quand
même relativement protégé la concurrence
donc vous voyez on ne sait pas sur ce
sujet battus pour défendre les
collectivités d'eric territoriales on
s'est battu pour faire en sorte que
cette baisse énorme de 8 milliards
d'euros soit réparti le mieux possible
entre les entreprises et notamment aux
bénéfices des entreprises industrielles
dont j'estime qu'elles sont pas assez
défendu dans notre pays serait une toute
autre affaire très rapidement vous allez
consulter la liste vous avez accès à la
liste des 3000 contribuables qui ont un
un compte en suisse et qui veulent
régulariser leur situation d'ici la fin
de l'année
pour l'heure ça semble fonctionner
moyennement parle de 250 personnes qui
se seraient manifestés c'est pas
beaucoup à 250 sur 3000 je trouve que
c'est déjà un bon résultat mais non le
ministre eric woerth nous a demandé à
didier migaud et moi même puisqu'on ne
peut pas nous opposer à tous les deux le
secret fiscal de consulter cette liste
et nous avons accepté tous les deux
parce que nous estimons que c'est de
notre devoir de vérifier quand on est
président la commission des finances
rapporteur du budget que l'impôt qui est
due par les français et bienne a quittés
si une question vous savez d'équité
parce que ce qui n'est pas payée par les
uns parce que par exemple ils vont faire
de l'évasion fiscale allait ouvrir des
comptes en suisse ce sera payé par les
autres sans compter qu'on va me
rapporter combien
au final on est incapable de le dire
aujourd'hui mais vous voyez bien que le
fait de vérifier qu'il ya bien trois
mille noms avec des sources bien
authentifié avec des éléments
extrêmement précis ça permet d'envoyer
un message à un certain nombre de
français en leur disant mais vous pouvez
très bien elle parmi ces 3000 et donc
nous vous demandons une chose c'est de
régulariser votre situation
voilà on va maintenant passer à
l'actualité de mardi en compagnie
notamment de dominique de villepin
à peine sorti du procès clearstream
dominique de villepin organisée autour
de lui un rassemblement de ses fidèles
et admirateurs il y avait l'ancien
premier ministre n'a pas attendu le 28
juin prochain l annonce du jugement dans
l'affairé clearstream pour préparer le
terrain des présidentielles de 2012
et sans surprise il le fait une attaque
en règle du pouvoir actuel pays
le peux vivre avec une concentration du
pouvoir une personnalisation du pouvoir
qui nuit à son efficacité
nous le voyons avec les mots que sont
les specs couru le voyons avec les mots
que sur la bureaucratie plus le pouvoir
est concentré moins il est efficace
est-ce qu'on peut reconnaître à
dominique de villepin une combativité
sans relâche
dominique de villepin est passionné de
politique
quelques-uns de mes collègues de la
majorité ils sont pas nombreux c'est
vrai mais quelques-uns bon le
soutiennent moi j'estime que c'est ça le
jeu de la démocratie
vous pensez qu'il va jouer un rôle
politique dans les années où dans les
mois à venir
je suis incapable de vous le dire ce que
je sais c'est qu'il a une grande
combativité on passe au mercredi
maintenant et la contre attaque l'aide
de charles pasqua condamné dans la
sphère des ventes d'armes à l'angola
trafic d'armes corruption le tribunal
correctionnel de paris à la main lourde
dans son jugement sur l'angolagate
condamnation la plus spectaculaire celle
de charles pasqua à un an de prison
ferme l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
fait immédiatement appel ils contre
attaquent ils demandent la levée du
secret défense dans toutes les affaires
de ventes d'armes
il vient de dire sur le plateau de
public sénat les explications avec marie
brémaud tout dévoiler c'est désormais le
parti pris de charles pasqua
mais le sénateur pour le moment ne
balance pas il souhaite que ce soit
l'état qui sortent du placard les vieux
dossiers qu'il lève le secret défense
sur tout non seulement su ans sur cette
affaire-là
mais qui le lève également sur
clearstream
certains essaient vos demandes et il
lève sur les ventes d'armes à
l'afghanistan sur les frégates de taïwan
il faut tout lever allez à l'origine de
ces déclarations la condamnation hier de
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur pour
trafic d'influencé dans le cadre de
ventes d'armes à l'angola dans les
années 1990 mais pour certains
connaisseurs du dossier la demande de
levée du secret défense n'est qu'un
vaste écran de fumée il n'y a pas de
secret défense
en quelques quelque nature que ce soit à
lever pour la raison très simple c'est
que l'on connaît toute la vérité on
connaît grâce au jugement
les personnes qui ont reçu de l'argent
de de falcone et gaydamak et on sait où
ont été vendus les armes diversion
menaces voilées ou simple coup de bluff
la bataille engagée par charles pasqua
contre la culture du secret en france
intervient quelques jours après la
déclassification par la ministre de
l'intérieur de dossiers concernant
l'attentât de karachi
concernant l' angolagate le porte parole
du gouvernement a précisé aujourd'hui
que la demande formulée par le sénateur
des hauts-de-seine seraient examinées
gilles carrez jouait la commission des
finances à l'assemblée vous êtes assez
sourcilleux en matière d'utilisation des
fonds publics
est-ce que vous pensez que cette espèce
d'opacité qui entoure les ventes d'armes
ça peut durer encore longtemps
ça ne durera pas je pense d'ailleurs que
dans cette affaire une partie non
négligeable du secret défense a été
levée à un certain nombre de documents
étaient déclassifiés et je pense que bon
donc l'argument dessous parce qu'on
n'est pas bons certains éléments ne sont
toujours pas moi j'observe que charles
pasqua est beaucoup plus 10 r
aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'était hier
et je pense que pour se former un
jugement il faudrait avoir bon la
totalité des pièces mais une partie
substantielle a déjà été déclassifiés
vous pensez que ce secret défense est un
peu un moyen commode de pas toujours
rendre des comptes est ce que vous par
exemple dans vos missions de contrôle
qui ne fait pas la commission des
finances où vous a déjà opposé le secret
défense
non non et je pense que on a tout
intérêt à rendre les choses les plus
transparentes possibles
c'est vraiment la voie qu'il faut suivre
sur tous ces dossiers alors sans le
pasqua pour vous mène un combat perdu
tout dépend de ce qu'il y a dans la
partie qui n'a pas été levé ça je suis
incapable de le dire une partie
substantielle a été levée
même si la partie de documents qui
restent confidentielles comprend des
éléments totalement nouveau attendons
que les décisions soient prises et la
france a encore raison de se battre pour
ses ventes d'armes on est dans les
quatre premiers exportateurs vers le
moment nous avons perdu du terrain
nous avons perdu du terrain il faut pas
non plus être angélique et rhinos ans
quand je vous dis qu'on a tout intérêt à
gagner en transparence je pense que un
peu comme dans le registre de la crise
financière c'est au niveau international
des grands pays exportateurs qu'il faut
essayer de mettre en place des règles
plus transparentes
parce que ces problèmes de ventes
d'armes vous les avez de la même manière
dans tous les pays producteurs vous les
avez aux états unis vous les avez eu en
grande bretagne vous ailleurs cosby en
allemagne aussi non le prêt il faut bien
distinguer deux choses il ya les
commissions et puis allez
rétrocommissions je pense que il faut
être absolument inflexible sur la
question des rétrocommissions et c'est
là qu'on avait râlé commission personnel
supplémentaire non ce les
retrocommissions ce sont des retours
vous verser une commission
un pays dans lesquels les règles
démocratiques ou transparence fonctionne
pas et en contrepartie une partie de
cette commission vous est renvoyé dans
le pays d'origine
et là ça pose un énorme problème mais il
faut pas non plus être complètement
génique
si des marchés importants ne peuvent
être que gagner que parce que ben il
faut à la clé verser des commissions
si nous nous sommes les seuls nous
français a refusé de verser de telles
commissions
on peut dire au revoir à notre industrie
de l'armement qui a toujours été une
industrie très performante que ce soit
dans l'aéronautique
que ce soit par exemple dans la
fabrication de véhicules terrestres
blindé de toutes sortes dans la halle
dans la marine
donc c'est des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois qui sont en jeu aussi
l'autre question gilles carez la france
at-elle trop et mal dépensé pendant ses
six mois de présidence européenne un
rapport de la cour des comptes effectuée
à la demande du sénat épingle ce
mercredi quelques dérives tout
particulièrement dans l'organisation du
sommet de l'union pour la méditerranée
en juillet 2008 à paris
les explications de germain andrieu lui
salon douche comprise pour 245 milles
euros
un dîner à 5000 euros par personne à
l'origine de ces polémiques
un rapport de la cour des comptes et une
facture la présidence française de
l'union européenne aura coûté plus de
170 millions d'euros dans ce rapport
commandé par le sénat l'organisation du
sommet de l'union pour la méditerranée
en juillet 2008 a généré plusieurs
dépenses hors norme en pleine présidence
française
la facture de ce sommet dépasse les 16
millions d'euros financé de manière
dérogatoire et selon ce rapport sans
aucune décision formelle sur le budget
de la présidence européenne organisée
dans l'urgence le réaménagement du grand
palais a coûté très cher mais pas
question selon l'ump de laisser mentir
l'opposition ces deux cent quarante cinq
mille euros correspondent à
l'aménagement de huit salons pour
personnalité et donc nous sommes très
très loin de ce qu'affirment les
socialistes deuxièmement le repas à 5000
euros
mais monsieur dosière chauffe
fou des français littéralement c'est un
mensonge pur et simple page 40 2 du
rapport de la cour des comptes
il est précisé que le coût de ce dîner
est de 310 euros par tête de pipe si
vous me permettez l'expression et la
cour des comptes souligne que c'est tout
à fait dans la norme de ce que dépense
normalement le ministère des affaires
étrangères pour recevoir ses hôtes au
quai d'orsay
piqué au vif rené dosière est venu
répondre chiffres à l'appui à ces
accusations
il persiste et signe le chiffre est le
chiffre même de la cour des comptes chez
le rapport ici sous les yeux
la cour des comptes vous dit que le
total atteint du dîner pour 200
personnes pourraient avoisiner donc il
donne le détail des dépenses auquel
s'ajoute un million en aménagement soit
un total de 20 millions 72 437 euros
pour 200 personnes soit 5 1367 euros par
invité
c'est clair est ce que c'est bien
d'avoir un monsieur dosière à
l'assemblée qui met le nez dans les
comptes comme ça oui mais les nez dans
les cordes par le tout petit bout de la
lorgnette moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
le chiffre de 170 millions d'euros
je le compare à la présidence allemande
qui étaient autour de 180 millions de
résidents se refermer les autres
présidences européennes quand elles sont
exercées par des pays de taille réduite
comme bon la république tchèque
récemment
la suède encore aujourd'hui bon c'est
évident que ces pays peuvent pas on sait
la maison donc on part en nous à
l'allemagne quand elle a présidée
comparant nous royaume uni quand il a
présidé et nous sommes dans les mêmes
eaux claires en sort quand même j'ai le
kharrazi semble quand même et là tout le
monde a l'air d'être unanimes que des
règles de marchés publics n'ont pas été
respectées dans l'urgence est ce qu'il
faut pas être un peu plus vigilant et
oui alors il faut être certainement un
peu plus vigilant mais en même temps on
ne peut pas tout faire passer par les
règles habituelles de la commande
publique parce que il ya réellement
urgence sur un certain nombre de cas de
sujets je prends l'exemple du sommet de
la méditerranée
bon il a été monté dans des conditions
difficiles on a réussi à avoir l'accord
de tous les chefs d'états et c'est
important
il est évident qu'on pouvait pas dire
bah on le repousse d'un mois parce qu'on
n'a pas passé on n'est pas passé par la
procédure d de la commande publique ce
serait complètement absurde
il reste que dans l'île séguin quand
même persisté cette semaine il dit c'est
pas un épisode très glorieux pour nos
finances publiques
c'est vrai et président de la cour des
comptes non mais bon c'est vrai que on
préférerait ont préféré que
bon un peu plus de rigueur soit apportée
mais sur quelques cas emblématiques
parfois même à la limite du grotesque
comme la sa fameuse douche parce que
quand on regarde de plus près ce que la
crise c'est pas ça du tout bon on a payé
le fait que nous n'avons plus les locaux
de l'avenue kléber qui servait aux
rondes de conférences iront à versailles
2 contres ference bon il coûtait en
permanence mais quand on accueillait une
conférence évidemment la conférence
coûter moins cher puisqu'elles étaient
hébergés mais ce centre lui écouter
toute l'année même quand y avait pas de
conférence pour vous nous l'avons nous
l'avons vendu
bon il ya des surcoûts il faut essayer
de concilier la souplesse nécessaire
parce que les événements se succèdent à
grande vitesse il faut faire face
et puis un minimum de rigueur moi je
pense que à partir du rapport de la cour
des comptes l'important c'est de tirer
un certain nombre d'enseignements
c'est surtout ça mais surtout 176
millions c'est comparable avec les
grands pays qui avant nous ont présidé
l'union européenne
allez on va encore parler 2013 on passe
à la journée de jeudi avec cette
question être champion de foot doit-il
donner le droit à des privilèges fiscaux
c'était donc le premier combat dans
l'hémicycle pour le député judoka david
douillet mais il l'a perdu une majorité
de députés a voté jeudi la fin des
exonérations de charges dont bénéficient
quelques 1200 sportifs de haut niveau au
titre du droit à l'image
un amendement sur lequel d'ailleurs le
gouvernement s'est divisée explications
avec hélène langis hardy pour défendre
les avantages des sportifs de haut
niveau
c'est l'un d'entre eux qui s'est exprimé
cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle quand
quand on change les règles en cours du
jeu on va mettre en péril des clubs et
vous allez avoir un pan un pan du sport
français qui va tomber
sachez le nom mais comprenez le bien et
y ai bien conscience de ça vraiment dans
son combat david douillet était soutenu
par l'ancien ministre des sports
jean-françois lamour
ils ont défendu une niche fiscale
réservé aux sportifs de haut niveau au
nom
la compétitivité des clubs français mais
rien n'y a fait l'amendement a été
adopté avec le soutien du rapporteur
ces jeunes ont la chance de gagner
beaucoup d'argent et on ne leur dénie
pas le talent et le droit de gagner de
l'argent mais je crois que quand on a
cette chance
on peut contribuer à la solidarité
nationale et celui du gouvernement à la
mise en place du dispositif depuis cinq
ans n'a pas empêché les départs massifs
notamment deux des joueurs de la ligue 1
de football vers les championnats
étrangers
la mesure devrait rapporter 35 millions
d'euros à l'état certes pas de quoi
combler les déficits pour l'auteur de
l'amendement
c'est avant tout pragmatique est
symbolique c'est toujours très petit par
rapport aux objectifs mais je crois
d'une part les petits ruisseaux font les
grandes rivières et je crois également
que cette toussaint sujet emblématique
quelque chose qui est connue qui
observaient de nos concitoyens et qu'à
ce titre tout ce qui est emblématique
toit d'une manière ou d'une autre
montrer l'exemple
pour ce député ump la lutte contre les
niches fiscales des sportifs n'est pas
fini il promet de remettre le sujet sur
la table au plus vite
alors comme vous êtes un de vos
collègues dans chaque niche il ya un
chien qui aboie on vient de le voir est
ce que c'est une bonne mesure qui a été
adoptée la par l'assemblée c'est une
mesure beaucoup trop rapide et brutale
on est sans arrêt en train de changer
les règles fiscales et donc cette
instabilité c'est la pire des choses a
été mis en place un dispositif jusqu'en
2012 bon
regardons sur la période des cinq ans
comment ça fonctionne faisons une
évaluation
une fois que le dispositif sera venu à
échéance et puis changeant les règles
contre la remise en cause à la mission
de voler à la commission des finances
avait le volet fiscal notamment lissage
des revenus
et puis sur l'aspect social de la
question qui exonère dans le cas de 30 %
dans le cadre du budget nous avons eu à
connaître de ce sujet la semaine
dernière
moi je me suis opposé aux amendement de
marc le fur parce que j'estime que il
faut laisser le dispositif vivre sa vie
mon nom est sur le devant des biens
correspondants de l'argent partout les
sur le périphérique sur le droit
l'image est tout un ensemble de choses
qui n'ont pas été vues et notamment la
vie des clubs sportifs même il n'y a pas
que le football j'ai eu l'occasion de
voir de plus près ce qui se passait sur
le rugby ça peut être une catastrophe
pour le fonctionnement nos clubs de
rugby
nous nous avons la chance à la
commission des finances d'avoir un
collègue qui connaît très bien ses
sujets qui en plus est très rigoureux
par rapport à l'argent public et jean
françois lamour
moi ce que m'a expliqué jean françois
lamour m'a tout à fait convaincu non
mais enfin quand un footballeur 45000
euros par mois et c'est une moyenne pour
la ligue 1 vous comprenez quand même les
français sont choqués d'apprendre qu'ils
bénéficient d'un lissage de ses impôts
qu une partie de sa rémunération est
exonérée de cotisations sociales
c'est pas acceptable en temps de crise
il met alors je vous demanderais est ce
qu'il est juste de refuser le lissage
des impôts un footballeur et de
l'accepter pour un chanteur ou pour un
écrivain
moi je pense que si le problème des
artistes des sportifs bon de haut niveau
doit être traité il doit l'être de façon
équitable en considérant l'ensemble de
ces professions pourquoi aller ciblé
d'un seul coup brutalement les seuls
footballeurs qu'ils ont regardé une
remise à plat les seniors commencer ça
me paraît une évidence
on a on est en train d'expérimenter un
dispositif
laissons un peu de temps en france et
eric ont dit qu'ils étaient prêts à ce
que ça n'a pas empêché les joueurs il a
compté un serpent plus est vu par n'a
pas suffisamment de recul
écoutez il faut qu'on arrête cette
maladie française qui consiste à créer
une règle
une année à la changer deux ans après à
y revenir quatre ans après et a sans
arrêt bouleversé la règle fiscale
ce qu'il faut avant tout en matière de
fiscalité c'est de la stabilité l'unité
dans l'injustice mais c'est pas une
injustice parce que on se focalise sur
les footballeurs en tant qu'individu
mais regardez aussi le fonctionnement
des clubs les clubs ce sont des
entreprises
les clubs c'est tout un secteur
d'activité personne n'a été capable de
me dire concrètement qu'elles risquaient
d'être le laf l'incidence sur la vie de
nos clubs sportifs allez on continue
cette journée du jeudi avec la polémique
qui monte autour de dispositifs
gouvernementale autour de la grippe a
mise en cause la transparence des
contrats signés avec les laboratoires
pour les vaccins qui vont être
disponible pour le grand public à la
rentrée après les vacances de la
toussaint contesté également la
communication autour de la campagne de
vaccination alors que seulement 17% des
français aujourd'hui se disent
disponibles pour être vaccinés julia le
caureq la campagne vaccinale du
gouvernement remise en cause alors que
la pandémie repart de plus belle
lancé par roselyne bachelot la semaine
dernière elle concerne dans un premier
temps le personnel de santé
le 12 novembre elle sera étendue au
reste de la population en commençant par
les personnes les plus fragiles
reste que selon un sondage paru dimanche
seuls 17% des français envisageraient de
se faire vacciner
à gauche on met en cause une mauvaise
communication ne constate que la
campagne de vaccination ne se passe pas
bien il ya à l'évidence beaucoup de
défiance chez tous les français et y
compris au sein du corps médical
je pense que c'est en grande partie liée
à une mauvaise communication de la part
du gouvernement
autre question posée elle aussi par le
parti socialiste
elle concerne les contrats relatifs aux
commandes de vaccins
la nature exacte des contrats
d'acquisition il m'a été assurée qu'au
départ on avait versé simplement des
arts or je découvre à la presse ce matin
que
les vaccins aurait été payée en totalité
pourquoi le prix des vaccins varie-t-il
temps d'un laboratoire un autre
l'hebdomadaire le point ce matin dénonce
le secret entourant ses commandes en
plein débat sur le plfss gérard bapt qui
n'a pas pu consulter les documents dans
l'après-midi interpelle le gouvernement
je demande à consulter ces contrats si
il ya toute transparence et s'il n'y a
aucun problème je ne vois pas pourquoi
on me les caches mais vous ne pouvez
aller à l'eprus et on voulait montrera
l'eprus si vous voulez tout de suite
écoutez prenez votre voiture allez-y
tout de suite si vous m'accuser de
cacher quelque chose dans ces contrats
prenez votre voiture vivait avec lui le
ps a demandé la création d'une mission
parlementaire sur le sujet sa demande a
pour l'instant été rejetée une mission
d' enquête çà vous semblera et gérard
bapt qui est un député de grande qualité
et rapporteur spécial à la commission
des finances il a le pouvoir de contrôle
sur pièces et sur place
quand roselyne bachelot lui d'y aller
voir les contrats ya aucun problème il
aurait pu aller voler voir il ya huit
jours il ya quinze jours il faut un pays
qu'il n'y a pas eu accès mais non mais
donc ce qu'il faut je suis d'accord avec
les cités transparence mais je peux vous
dire une chose
en tant que rapporteur spécial les
médecins de surcroît et il connaît
parfaitement le sujet s'ils veulent
informations il peut la voir
donc je souhaiterais que ces sujets qui
sont trop gras ne soit pas l'objet d'un
strict de polémiques de nature politique
si notre rapporteur spécial veut faire
son travail il peut le faire et c'est
une très bonne chose puisque le groupe
d'expertisé et d'information sur la
grippe qui conseille le ministère de la
santé est financé à 100% par les
laboratoires qui produisent ces vaccins
vous pensez que c'est simple parce qu'on
leur en conseiller dans d'une manière
générale il faut qu'on soit beaucoup
plus attentif sur ses liens de
financement entre cousins valoir m
laboratoire et et milieux médicaux je
pense que quand une mission publique
officielle qui confier
à tel ou tel médecin il faut au
préalable s'assurer de l'interruption
des liens ou de la non existence de
liens
vous êtes d'accord qu'il ya
dysfonctionnement alors je ne connais
pas bien le sujet mais s'il y avait des
liens
oui ça fait vraiment son firme et par
sanofi pascual ab je pense que c'est
regrettable
il ya 80 dès lors qu'il ya des liens à
tort ou à raison il y aura suspicion
voilée sur ces sujets de santé
il n'y a rien de pire que la suspicion
les sujets de santé exige par définition
la confiance aujourd'hui à 80 % des
français qui disent qu'ils vont pas se
faire vacciner est ce que vous ne
craignez pas qu'on découvre dans toute
cette politique autour de la grippe à
une sorte de fiasco de la politique
publique
les pouvoirs publics sont confrontés au
fameux principe de précaution
moi je le vois en ce président on en
fait trop peut-être mais on se pose sans
arrêt la question mais en tant que maire
du perreux
on a été conduit parce qu'on les ferme
dans le vin d'augmenter à commander des
milliers de mâts ça représente une
dépense de 15000 euros
ça me rend malheureux de me dire ses
15000 euros
ils vont peut-être se traduire par le
stockage de masques qui vont rester là
pendant des années et qu'on compte
détruira est-ce que c'est pas un
gaspillage d'argent mais d'un autre côté
nous avons érigé en règle absolue de
fonctionnement de notre démocratie on
l'a même inscrire dans la constitution
le principe de précaution est la
déclinaison du risque zéro
alors on est tiraillé entre ces deux
exigences va trop loin parce qu'il ya la
paix au po sélections l'audi a eu le
syndrome de la canicule ou en ariège
c'est tellement pouvoirs publics de
n'avoir rien fait peut-être cette fois
on fait de la surenchère j'appelle
vraiment je me pose cette question mais
tout simplement jouer profiter les
missions pour dire qu' il vaut mieux se
faire vacciner
il vaut mieux se faire vacciner chaque
année contre la grippe
c'est une bonne décision oui mais tu as
contre la grippe en général parce que
beaucoup de français et notamment comme
pour les personnes âgées se faire
vacciner c'est mieux que de pas se faire
vacciner du tout le rémois faire passer
le message
ça me pense que frêche parce que celle
attendue
est-ce que donc ce principe de
précaution qui coûte très cher vous
pensé quand même qu'il faut il faut le
maintenir il faut il faut je m'interroge
beaucoup moi je lui attirer la tâche un
peu plus oui parce que il faut qu'on
définisse aujourd'hui des règles
d'évaluation d'appréciation de kout deux
variantes si je tend à être je
schématise si vous voulez être à 95% de
nos risques
vous allez dépenser 100 si vous les
voulez passer à 99% vous allez dépenser
300 parce que c'est la couverture du du
risque ultime qui fait que les prix
s'envolent
moi j'observe que aujourd'hui nous avons
des centaines de milliards de déficit
nous sommes en train de laisser à nos
enfants des montagnes de dettes qui vont
se traduire pour eux par un dramatique
baisse de pouvoir d'achat
il ya peut-être des standards de nous
sommes dotés ces dernières années qu'il
faudra probablement revoir
en tout cas je souhaiterais que le sujet
soit mis sur la table de corps allez on
passe à la journée du vendredi et le
coup de tonnerre judiciaire jacques
chirac est renvoyé en correctionnelle
et un ancien chef de l'état qui rendent
des comptes à la justice c'est une
première en cette fin de semaine jacques
chirac est donc renvoyé devant le
tribunal correctionnel de paris pour
détournement de fonds publics et abus de
confiance pour 21 emplois fictifs
présumés à la mairie de paris jacques
chirac donc rattrapé par la justice
après douze ans d'immunité pénale
c'est un sujet de thomas souligne un
ancien président de la république devant
la justice c'est une première en france
à 76 ans jacques chirac devra
s'expliquer sur la sphère des 21 emplois
supposés fictifs lorsqu'il était maire
de paris
ces chefs d'accusation détournement de
fonds publics et abus de confiance
protégé durant douze ans par son
immunité présidentielle jacques chirac
est redevenu un justiciable ordinaire
dans un communiqué publié ce matin
il se dit serein et décidé à établir
qu'au camp des postes ne constitue un
emploi fictif pour la droite
l'histoire appartient au passé c'est pas
une affaire qu'on découvre aujourd'hui
il ya déjà eu des jugements et comme il
y avait eu des jugements en ce qui me
concerne même si vous savez que
normalement n'a pas prendre part dans un
dossier comme celui ci je pense qu'il
n'est pas utile de revenir encore et
encore en arrière
ce matin à l'assemblée chacun y va de
son petit commentaire
à gauche on salue la décision de justice
c'est une décision courageuse de la
justice et une décision justifiée
moi j'ai été conseillère de paris j'ai
vu quand même en place le système chirac
et j'ai quand même invraisemblable
qu'aujourd'hui on puisse dire que parce
que jacques chirac a un certain âge
parce que il a été président de la
république il doit pas répondre de ses
actes délictueux devant la justice il
faut maintenant souhaiter que le
processus puisse se dérouler de la
manière la plus sereine et encore j'ai
envie d'être la plus calme possible sans
acharnement
moi je ne suis pas de ceux qui pensent
qu'il faut à tout prix faire payer faire
mettre un genou à terre à des
responsables politiques sous prétexte
que on les a combattus sur le terrain
politique mais maintenant c'est à la
justice de dire
ce don est responsable jacques chirac le
parquet a cinq jours pour contester la
décision
si c'est le cas la cour d'appel de paris
décidera du renvoi ou non de jacques
chirac devant les tribunaux j'ai eu 15
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est la fin
d'un système d'une époque
enfin moi je suis surtout très déçu
parce que bon jacques chirac a été mon
ministre premier ministre maire de paris
président de la république
il a vraiment beaucoup donné à notre
pays bon il est aujourd'hui à la
retraite et je pense que vraiment le
plus sage utt de loin qu'on lui laisse
bon couler des jours paisibles de
retraite on pourrait d'ailleurs de la
fellation entre partie de la de
l'infection wild en sélection de de
beaucoup de français
et puis je m'interroge sur les effets
quant à l'image de notre pays à
l'extérieur ça ça me préoccupe beaucoup
et donc bon ces affaires qui ont été
jugés re jugé une fois deux fois dix
fois
enfin les demi finales en douze ans
c'est normal qu'on soit rattrapé par des
chants ciel je trouve encore plus normal
que quelqu'un qui a assumé des fonctions
pour son pays
aussi éminente que lui avait quand même
l'assentiment général
bon on n'aille pas le rechercher vingt
ans après sur des histoires qui ont déjà
été jugés et puis je j'estime aussi
qu'on doit faire attention à l'image de
notre pays
allez pour terminer le clin d'oeil de la
semaine le copier-coller déniché par nos
confrères de canal plus nicolas sarkozy
était cette semaine devant les
agriculteurs du jura mais les mots
sonnaient comme la réplique exacte d'un
précédent discours sur l'agriculture en
février dernier regard des agriculteurs
et donc un autre repreneur
maintenant prenez rohner qui noircissent
à 16 heures qui porte la responsabilité
d'un verdissement important il y aura
enlevé deux défis humains financiers
techniques et d'istres administratif
considérable et culture a façonné nos
paysages
laquelle
parties de son âme toutes les familles
de france ont des grands-parents tient
sûrement moins au travail et baye et la
terre moi je ne suis pas venu vous tenir
un discours que vous avez déjà entendu
alors un commentaire il ya un
collaborateur qui s'est pas beaucoup
fatigué parce que comme on le voit bon
nicolas sarkozy y met toute son âme
toutes ses tripes dans ce discours 1000
collaborateurs lui pour ce qui s'est
fait un peu taper sur les doigts
j'espère oui j'espère parce que bon on
va les réécrire le discours qu'on a fait
un en avant c'est pas c'est pas sérieux
le message est passé un monsieur sarkozy
c'est pas sérieux quand même ce que vous
avez fait non non je ne sais pas le
président sarkozy le président il a des
disques warfare tous les jours ce sont
ses collaborateurs là qui sont en cause
on n'a pas à réécrire le même discours
qu'un an avant
voilà merci en tout cas jusqu'à z on
essaiera de prendre de nouvelles de
nouvelles questions nous pour la semaine
prochaine
voilà merci beaucoup hélas devenu et
puis nous nous retrouvons avec emmanuel
la semaine prochaine vous ne leur
donnent rendez vous même lieu même heure